yeah welcome to a new video do cream
yeah okay so let's play place I'm
opening the Kings Indian and what do we
get the classical know the sameish yeah
c5 I really don't know this pawn
sacrifice line let's play some some
offbeat variation now you can go right
edge three okay it doesn't
aha so we have some kind of benoni but
ah like to see one yeah this is not
uncommon and in this slide okay play six
he probably will play a four no it
doesn't okay so i'll go for b5 better
better now then having it prevented all
the time night c4 is a good source of
counter play okay I ok he wants to he
wants to play with with before so is
there some technical way to go about
that before Ted takes Knight g4 takes 94
yeah not not sure Quincy seven maybe
before take stakes is there some some
shot on the long diagonal it really
looks like there should be something
I've got just night c4 which isn't too
bad but
hmm interesting this direct before some
interesting idea ok I can go see phone
before I don't like that
there really is no tactical trachea on
this very weak diagonal hmm bit of a
shame bit of a shame okay let them play
this threatening 94 now maybe maybe I'm
threatening this but I was writing
Knight g4 this is this is Sir this is a
certain team okay is covering this I'd
like to play a 5 a-5 takes and before
this looks like a dynamic continuation
not sure if it's a good continuation but
it's a very very much in the spirit of
this opening yeah come on push the apron
the only thing that worries me is a rook
see one the screen doesn't have much sue
it doesn't have many squares doesn't
have fun hmm am I going actually rook FC
one takes on before an ID be one is it
trapped or something looks looks
dangerous maybe I can sacrifice the
Queen in some nice way okay I'm done he
didn't play it like this
we should be sure to d7 simply in order
to recapture on a 5 or is a for a movie
IFI probably goes Roxy one let's try to
protect this year after this he cannot
move the night at least
maybe just rope takes mmm just rook
takes this is uh this is tricky now take
on H was stupid
94 Stan 94 fe for bishops III okay come
on I hope that I'm not overlooking
something easy because the night takes
the screen before rook takes the screen
a to greene takes also create two so i
should get it back Roxy for Bishop d to
take here I bishop age 60 wow this is
this is really weak the dark squares wow
wow
yeah just bishop age six and I'm
probably gone or maybe other moves
Quincy seven or something but Bishop age
six I probably need to play hmm don't
know bish look ah this one he wants to
really set up some some some better in
here with Bishop to Bishop to deform I
always have from rookie five though John
let's play this I'm attacking see one I
had this of course it also has got
Bishop age 60
yes okay black resigns yeah okay this
was 94 was a fun shot but it's it's
simply not not working because of this
Queen f6 was a strong move this finishes
me off really i don't i don't have a
reply so yeah but this means that I'm in
trouble here maybe maybe I have instead
of Bishop d7 EA for I considered this
briefly but it looks so strange I
thought that a for look here now it's
also better for white with screen going
yeah I didn't really have managed here
ninety-seven normally maybe I cannot
afford to play five maybe better 97 the
problem with this structure here is the
week c 6 square knight on d4 can go to c
6 and so on but the night is far away
from from the d 4 square so maybe this
isn't so terrible i thought i needed to
get instant immediate counter play but
with a five but maybe this is not the
case and i can just play play other
moves like this 97 and then possibly not
see force for a later stage maybe you
had the Benoni as always so it's
complicated yeah thanks for watching
interesting game